[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening from Westminster this
coming week will see the United Kingdom
May one of the most historic decisions
that this country has taken since the
Second World War our elected members of
parliament must decide whether to
support tourism A's agreements with the
EU paving the way for brexit on March
the 29th next year the government
claimed that to reject the deal could
lead to Britain crashing out of the EU
with no deal and no transition and they
say with appalling economic consequences
all they say their opponents might try
to ensure that there is no brexit at all
so who will prevail the will of those
seventeen million people is expressed in
2016 all the votes of 650 MPs or at
least a majority of them when they are
cast in the days to come
something will have to give after two
years of argument we are finally now
reaching decision time and that is the
subject of tonight's intelligence
squared debate we will in fact hear from
three people tonight with three very
different perspectives starting off
making the case for Tereza maize draught
withdrawal agreement from the EU is
Nicky Morgan former Secretary of State
for Education under Prime Minister David
Cameron and currently the Conservative
MP for loft bruh Nicky Morgan
before we go any further perhaps I could
just ask are there any other members of
parliament in this room tonight okay I
think unless someone's going to tell me
I'm missing a hand I am the only person
in this room who will get a vote on the
Prime Minister's draught withdrawal
agreement and political declaration next
Tuesday leaving aside the calls for a
second vote which I know that Andrew
will be advancing so yes I'm here to
talk on behalf of the prime minister's
draft withdrawal agreement which I
intend to vote for next Tuesday but I
think I'm actually also here to talk for
the silent majority of this country who
are very very frustrated by brexit
they're very very depressed by what they
see in Westminster they're very very
uncertain about what the future holds
the conversations I've had at the
weekend are people who are looking for
reassurance from their leaders that
there is a plan that the plan can go
forward and that we move on to the next
stage of brexit as I said in the House
of Commons last week it is easy to
criticize somebody else's negotiations
it's easy to criticize something else
that someone has put on the table it's
easy for all of us to remain entrenched
in our brexit positions and that by and
large is what has happened leadership
and governing is about choosing and the
Prime Minister had done what was asked
of her she has negotiated an agreement
that means the UK will leave the
European Union but she has in our
national interest made sure that that
agreement will mitigate as much of the
economic uncertainty and instability as
it possibly can
stability is very important it might be
much mocked after the 2017 general
election but actually the stability of
this country is really really important
the stability of our people the
stability of our businesses our economic
environment the stability of young
people's future that they know
what to expect dan you set up in Oxford
a campaign for an independent Britain
you and your fellow campaigners are on
the verge of getting what you wanted
which is for the UK to leave the
European Union there is a date in the
diary for that - half of the 29th of
March 2019 it's not what I wanted but it
is going to happen out of the Powell
tonight I am arguably the only one who
directly represents constituents
I have 82,000 people who are at liberty
to call upon me as their Member of
Parliament regardless of whether they
voted for me I help them with housing I
help them with policing issues I help
them with deal with policy queries I
help charities to raise funds every else
that's what I want to be doing not
debating brexit and so for that wheeze
and I think it's time to move on but
that reason is an ardent remainer
I accept that we will be leaving the
European Union the question is how we do
it and I would say to you tonight that
both No Deal which were here advocated
and a second vote aren't true options
one risks disaster for our economy and
stability of our country one just
prolongs the agony Europe and brexit
have been Agony's of the Conservative
Party my party that I've been a member
of the nearly 30 years I'm afraid I'm
not going to indulge the brexit
ideologues
in the Conservative Party any longer in
fact I don't think I've done indulge
them since the autumn of 2016 the
Conservative Party is not an ideological
party it is a pragmatic party with some
core values and those values that
pragmatism is demonstrated by Teresa
Mays draft deal on the table I voted to
remain because I felt that it was right
party economically but also because it
was right for Britain's geo-political
role but that is going to change
seventeen million people voted for
change and I do understand why many of
them did and I don't know how widely
drawn this audience is tonight but let
me just tell you that London is a very
different country from the rest of the
United Kingdom and the outlook is very
very different a wise old General
said to me recently the United Kingdom
is known for its confidence and its
competence at the moment ladies and
gentlemen we are demonstrating neither
it is time to get on with it it is time
to prove the agreement and get on to the
next stage thank you for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
Nikki Morgan thank you very much indeed
so we've already heard the case for
Theresa Mays deal there from Nikki
Morgan it is now time to hear the first
argument against that deal and a demand
that the government tries at least to
renegotiate it and if it can't
renegotiate is prepared at least to
threaten to leave the EU with no deal
and no transition at all making the case
for that is Daniel Hannan conservative
member of the European Parliament for
southeast England and as you were just
hearing referred to by many as the
father of brexit ladies and gentlemen
Daniel Hannan Nick thank you very much
ladies and gentleman good evening I am a
huge admirer of the last speaker but I
can honestly tell you that I even in
these gender-fluid times never wanted to
be her until tonight because you see
nikki is taking the position in this
debate that I had always expected to be
taking at this point in our national
discourse I was never one of those
leaders who are by the way
extraordinarily few who wanted a WTO
terms deal it seems to me obvious almost
too obvious to need stating that we
should have the closest and friendliest
relations with our immediate neighbors
compatible with being a sovereign
democracy I spent two years arguing for
a kind of deal that would leave us after
like in the common market but outside
the institutions of common government
now some more hardline levers would say
what's the point about would be half in
half out might say yet you know what
that's how more or less how the country
voted so I always expected now to be
arguing for a moderate and reasonable
form of brexit you see when I said half
in half out I was making the assumption
that we would aim to keep the good half
and junk the bad half instead of which
incredibly for the government has come
back with a deal that does the opposite
this deal would keep us in everything
pretty much except the market would keep
us in with the same obligations on
defense
Krim
justice and so on and incredibly instead
of if you like doing a switzerland
instead of aiming to keep the single
market but junk the customs union and
thereby recover the commercial freedom
that is so vital to a country like ours
we're gonna be to the incredulity of our
friends in after looking to leave the
single market but stay in the customs
union now I've never heard anyone
explain why that makes sense as a policy
me that we would in other words have 100
percent brussels control of our trade
policy with zero percent control that
would have been laughed at by all sides
three years ago effect is even worse
than that more than 20 times the prime
minister ruled out customs union
membership and russia now presents us a
victory
being able to stay in as a way of
avoiding the northern ireland only back
stop my friends nor milan was only ever
a stalking horse used by the EU to try
and rate reach the position that they've
now reached where they can use the UK
market second-biggest in the EU the
fifth biggest in the world totally as a
bargaining chip to benefit the other
twenty seven clamps in the vise of the
customs union so that their exporters
face no competition i have to say as an
aside every possible mistake has been
made in the last two years
premature triggering of article 50 the
acceptance of the EU sequencing the
handing over of the money with before we
even begin trade talks and now this
appalling proposal though what happens
now what are the realistic options as
far as i can see there are only now two
options in the time available one is
that we come back with a slimmed down
version a minimalist version of this
deal following parliamentary rejection
on the 11th almost all of the objection
to this deal there are 585 pages of it
focus on 175 pages that pertain to the
irish backstop we can live with the
other 410 pages they're not perfect no
one really thinks we Oh bro CIL's 39
billion they give the ECJ a bit more of
a role than it sure but you know what we
could live with that what we can't
is a backstop which unlike EU membership
itself has no exit clause that is the
kind of deal that a defeated nation
signs under duress we either go back and
say look can we at least agree the
unconscious stuff are we really going to
say that we're going to junk the idea
for example of reciprocal rights for
each other's citizens the European Union
may accept that I think they need to be
a different Prime Minister that need to
be a prime minister who they didn't
think would sign whatever was put in
front of her it's possible or it is
possible that the European Union may say
no we're going to put politics before
economics we want to make an example of
you and we're prepared if necessary to
pay a price in order to be vindictive I
don't think so but if I'm wrong then for
heaven's sake let's have that
confrontation now because the only
argument then left for signing up to
this customs union for allowing the
mantrap to close and dig into our flesh
would be we want a quiet life in a short
term my friends you will find it better
policy to say we never pay anyone
dangled no matter how trifling the cost
for the end of that game is oppression
and shame and the nation that plays it
is lost
[Applause]
[Music]
let's move on to the next speech against
Teresa Mays deal with the EU but from a
very very different perspective against
the deal yes but in favor of a second
referendum on the deal with the option
of remaining in the EU after that our
speaker is Lord of donors Andrew adonus
a Labour Party peer who served as a
minister in the government to both Tony
Blair and Gordon Brown and is now a
passionate advocate of what he and the
campaign he supports calls a people's
vote
Andrew donors so it's great it's great
to be expected debating alongside Nikki
and Daniel Nikki said quite rightly in
it's an old French adage that leadership
and governing is about choosing that's
completely right Parliament has to
choose what to do with the Prime
Minister's withdrawal agreement what I
believe should happen is that Parliament
should choose to refer it to the people
so that they can on this huge issue just
look at the size of the turnout this
evening you all think it's a big an
important issue so that you can choose
what should happen because this is the
first time that we are going to know
what is going to happen to how much
we're going to pay the EU what's going
to happen to the rights of EU citizens
who live here the rights of British
citizens who are going to live who live
abroad what is going to happen in terms
of our trades no two years ago Daniel
told us there was no question about
place in the single market being
threatened we are leaving the single
markets we were told that we could stay
in the customs union we're leaving the
customs union all of these things we
were told two years ago have turned out
not to be true but now that we know what
the deal is in terms of the money in
terms of free movements of people in
terms of our trading relations in terms
of the Northern Irish border in terms of
the European Court of Justice all of
these critical issues what is the right
thing the right thing is that we the
people should make that decision and the
fact that my esteemed colleagues Daniel
and Nicky that we
actually have two people arguing for
different leave propositions this
evening explains to you why we need a
people's votes because there was not a
leave proposition on the ballot paper
two years ago there was a set of
unicorns there was the 350 million there
was that we can have our cake and eat it
on the economy there were all of these
propositions but there was no actual
worked up scheme for how we would leave
now I pay tribute to the Prime Minister
she has done her best I don't myself
think that she could have negotiated a
better deal and I think Nicky has done a
splendid job this evening in defending
her
but what's already clear is that the
bricks eaters themselves cannot agree on
whether or not this represents a good
brexit deal because two years ago there
was no scheme put forward Daniel said
Mrs May has made every possible mistake
this is an appalling proposal we can't
live with this backstop the Prime
Minister's kept the bat half and junked
good half Daniel was the person who was
busy telling us we should do this two
years ago let's be clear if Daniel is
right that this is I took him to say
didn't actually say on this occasion but
I believe he said in other occasions
that we're better off staying in the
European Union than going with this
proposal remember Jacob Riis Marcus said
that it's vassalage less that was
misunderstood because not everybody
deals in these medieval terms he said he
said he said last week that it wasn't in
fact vassalage it was slavery he says
slavery you are about to become slaves
but let's be clear Jacob and I assume
Daniel thinks you're about to become
slaves because you are agreeing the
brexit deal which Nicky is defending on
behalf of the government so one bit of
the Conservative Party is describing as
slavery the brexit deal which another
bits of the Conservative Party is
negotiating claiming the mandate from
you the people two years ago this is a
complete nonsense it is not a democratic
state of affairs at all now when we have
this referendum as I believe that we
will because the logic is now so strong
in favor there are four big arguments as
to why we should stay in the European
Union none of which are meant by the
treaty which the Prime Minister has
negotiated the first is to defend our
fade and out economy nearly half of our
traders with the EU another 15% is with
the 73 other countries with which the EU
has trading arrangements argument to
Ireland the only way not to have a
harder border in Ireland is not to leave
the EU which will ensure there is a hard
border argument three young people young
people do not want to be as one put it
to me yesterday
shut up on a small island with Jacob we
smoked
Nigel Faraj and Boris Johnson
[Applause]
and the fourth and five and the fourth
and final reason the fourth and final
reason is peace the EU is the biggest
and most successful peace project in the
history of Europe and we should defend
it
[Applause]
and we should and we should defend it in
a people's vote so I urge you to back a
second referendum
thank you very much
well ladies gentlemen before we hear
from you in the audience before we get
some debate amongst our speakers tonight
I want to tell you how people voted
before the debate began there's not a
representative audience there's not
being chosen by an opinion pollster and
the reason we take a vote at the
beginning and then again at the end is
to see whether arguments sway people or
whether people have already made up
their minds the most popular of the
three cases being presented before the
debate again was the case for a second
referendum with 46% of our audience
saying that they are in favor of it
second most popular but only just the
argument that was being put forward by
Daniel Hannan that the government should
renegotiate the terms and threaten to
leave without a deal 19% of people voted
for that Nicky Morgan document that you
should Beck and support to resumes deal
with the EU was backed just 1% less by
18 percent and just behind there
seventeen percent of you said that you
were undecided so we're going to begin
our discussion now in the audience we
have our speakers we're not inviting you
to give a speech we're inviting you to
make a short statement or to ask a short
question yes please yeah my questions to
daniel regarding leaving junking junking
to resumes deal and leaving without a
deal we default to WTO terms what
concrete evidence is there that were we
to leave without a deal and then to try
and negotiate free trade agreements that
we would get a deal any better than ours
from everything I see it would be worse
so you might just be clear that Theresa
Mays deal is therefore the right thing
to back I think it's the least worst
option we face at the moment if WTO
terms are so good and that's what we'd
end up with if there was no deal why was
part of the campaign to leave the EU
that we would form new trade deals with
China with America in other words not
on WT and of course WTO dick they are a
floor they're not an ideal then yes of
course we should aim to have free trade
agreement and I have to say around the
world countries including China and the
US the second largest and largest
economies in the world have indicated
that they want deep comprehensive free
trade agreements with an independent
United Kingdom on say don't worry the
customs union we can't so members the
audience oh yes sir
the gentlemen here at the front and
we've got a speaker over there who I
can't see thank you yes sir this peace
project isn't to well if we look at
Spain over recent days we've seen the
far right
having electoral success for the first
time since Franco if we look at France
we see the worst riots in a generation
if we're being told there's a great deal
with the European Union in terms of
young people then look at the mass
unemployment among young people in
Greece in Spain across the south of
Europe this is an appalling thing which
had been done to a generation of young
people and I'm concerned that if our
elites do not listen if they do not hear
what's going on then they will only be
able to fear just hold a response there
for Tuesday's yeah but it's great for
that
hi I'm supporting Nicky this evening in
the trees amazed deal and in part
because as an owner of a small business
I need the uncertainty to end and I
think that's the biggest factor for us
is that Android like to ask in relation
to the second referendum how do you stop
that becoming a third referendum a
fourth round at random and constant
uncertainty which means as a business
owner I can't invest for the future I
can't hire more people and returners
deal with that boy and then Nicky Morgan
back to the point about Spain until we
have got to decide of the country what
we do with this treaty we cannot duck we
have to decide the fact that we have to
take this decision does not mean that we
will then have referendums thereafter
one thing I can guarantee you guarantee
you is that no Prime Minister is going
to be calling another referendum on you
after the experience of the last three
years
once we've resolved this issue it's the
third rail of British politics it's not
going to happen we don't really have
made a powerful point that Europe where
my phrase not yours but is in flames and
the bits that arms in flames have very
high levels of youth unemployment and
very high levels of extremism so why
should we want to stay in this failing
project well and I've been very clear
that actually I think the argument has
been settled and has been had that we're
not going to be staying in and actually
the gentleman here perfectly illustrates
my my point sir I don't mean just to get
at you because I think your
representative of many people around the
country which is we're still fighting
the same battles of 2016 the fact is we
are still stuck where we were two years
ago UK politics has stalled and it is no
good the gentleman over here is
completely right about certainty for his
business this may not be a perfect deal
this may not be the kind of deal that
you would negotiate in your business but
it is a deal yeah question here hello as
a student from the cedar school of
Croydon
I wanted to ask Andrew a donees he
argued many points of the old referendum
of the the first one of brexit do you
know have any more new points to make of
the second referendum let's keep going
yeah question back there
I just wanted to ask um Andrew adonus
what his question would be for a second
referendum are you proposing we go right
back to the beginning and it's just
leave or remain or are we are you
suggesting that we vote on Theresa May
as Mays deal and are there one or two
other options that we'd vote on we're
gonna come back to the young man here in
just a second this has been asked of you
a couple of times as your donors I know
your answer is that you only care about
one of the options namely there remain
should be on the ballot paper but if
you're going to put the country through
another costly Reverend that that might
divide it again do you not have to spell
out to people what your vote on and how
the result will be determined okay can I
say that of course the House of Commons
will decide what the question is if
there's a referendum that's what it's
there to do it decides these things I
can only give you my view my it is
that they shot the choice which was put
to the people should be the only
credible choice which the people face
which is between tourism A's deal and
remaining in the EU we know that they're
credible because the Prime Minister has
negotiated her deal she spent two and a
half years doing it the EU has said
there can be no further negotiations so
we know that that's operable and we know
that we can stay in the EU because we're
there at the moment that should be the
choice that goes to the people but the
House of Commons will decide and it may
be that the House of Commons decides to
put a third option on which is something
like No Deal and my test of this would
be if Daniel Jacob Riis smoked Nigel
flush and Boris Johnson in a room
together can agree on what their No Deal
is and they can spell it out and we can
read it so that we can then test it so
it's not a set of unicorns which they
can all deny in a referendum campaign
then I'm happy for that to go on the
ballot paper
I suspect the chances of that happening
a remote you'd be very clear that you
don't want a second referendum but if
the House of Commons you're not in it
but if he were to choose to have a
second referendum would you insist that
there was a third option
leaving along the sorts of lines that
you've described enough well let me
answer that by saying this anyone who
wondered whether there was still such a
thing as a British establishment will
have had any doubt removed over the last
two years from the moment the vote was
in a group of people campaigned quite
openly you can't call it a conspiracy to
overturn the result and to end up with
with what Lord adonus has just said a a
choice between a rubbish deal and
staying it what would be my reaction if
there were that degree of
anti-democratic genteel coup I'll tell
you I think that the correct thing for
every lever at that stage would be to
refuse to participate in such a
referendum because we've already voted
you all told us that this was going to
be it you know Clegg and Ashdown and
Cameron and major they all said there's
never gonna be another vote now or never
for them now to dare to turn around and
say vote again well how many more times
right we shouldn't play that game we
should boycott Nicky Morgan what do you
think the referendum shoe
if there is one well first I don't think
there should be one and I would just say
to Dan to those people in the audience
who I don't fur I get constituency
nailing who are very firm you must vote
down this terrible deal we know we voted
to leave and everything else
if this Agreement does not go through
next Tuesday then there is a very real
possibility of there being a second
referendum because of the Labour Party
shifts its position to support a second
referendum officially and there are
enough colleagues on the conservative
bench that do it too that will go
through I for the reasons that I have
set out and dance it out I think that
would be extremely damaging I don't
think you could possibly though have
another vote without no deal being on
the table three you have to have three
options I don't make a nonsense of the
whole thing I want to take more members
the audience out please hi I think you
should with Daniel's comments or
dismissal of the second referendum on
the grounds of where you yourself have
just said you stood up and you say that
you wish you were here to support a deal
your mind about what breads it looks
like has changed in view of your
perception of the facts so why on earth
wouldn't the views of millions of other
people be able to change and what would
you deny yourself now maybe Morgan an
important question and quite a lot of
these audience questions are coming down
to the nature of a referendum and I know
again you're not arguing for it the
questions being asked how can you have a
referendum on a deal that's been
rejected if Parliament says no if the
government in other words has failed to
get its way there's a question mark over
the future the Prime Minister in that
circumstance it would seem to me
how could you then have a referendum on
something that in effect in political
terms doesn't exist anymore well I think
I said that's a very good point I mean
it goes back to why I think that a
second referendum opens up all sorts of
cans of of worms and I suppose you could
say that it's going to be something akin
to this deal and that the EU have made
it very clear that they are not going to
budge and we all know that of course in
a negotiation people say they're not
going to change their minds it's
possible that there might be something
about the deal that the EU does decide
to change if the vote is lost next
Tuesday there's an EU council meeting to
follow shortly after at the end
of next week but I think that again
points to the impossibility of the
situation I mean the lady at the
beginning when the ladies asked and it
should just be leave or remain
effectively who took the deal off the
table that the Primus negotiated you
just had remain as Andrew wants or no
deal as as Dan wants then actually
you're back to rerunning the arguments
of 2016 I don't want no deal there's
nobody who wants no deal you say this
not every smaug does not think leaving
me without a deal is a good is not a
profession yes it is not his preferred
option he would much rather have a deal
that is acceptable to both side so let
me just say what it is cuz I think this
is really important what is unacceptable
about this deal is a backstop which
unlike EU membership itself has no exit
clause that's that that we can't sign up
to and here's the paradox Brussels and
Dublin and London all say that they
never want that backstop to come into
effect
so are we really suggesting that the
whole of the rest of the withdrawal
agreement should be junked for the sake
of something that all of the
participants say they don't want if that
were to happen and if we were to go
ahead with No No Deal
it would rapidly become clear that there
was no physical border in Ireland my the
site is going to erect any
infrastructure at the frontier and so
the whole notion reason for having
created this impasse would have been
shown to have been the nonsense it was
from the beginning that we haven't quite
got to yet and I call back on that
comment about events dear boy events
because things may be superseded next
week we've already heard about um
they're potentially being in no
confidence vote in the government I see
the front page of The Times talked about
the DUP may not even support their
confidence to try partners what happens
if we get to the point where there's no
leadership no government and let alone
talking about referendums what about a
general election okay we'll talk about
that in just a second yes over there yes
Daniel
presumably as a conservative he believed
in financial markets and judgments they
make and over the last two years we've
seen sterling react very
negatively to any talk of a no deal I
was wondering whether that evidence
makes you doubt what he'd been doing for
the last 25 years of your life yeah
and I support our prime minister one for
Daniel he says that if the deal means
that we stay in the customs union yet
lorded owner says that the deal means we
leave I understand the backstop issue we
can't get out of it very easily but my
understand is if we do a trade deal with
the EU then we do leave the backstop and
therefore we leave the customs union why
would they do a deal what what could be
more favorable to the EU than having
this country permanently imprisoned in
the customs here well when you say
imprison let's just pursue the backstop
which just to remind people the backstop
is on the one hand meant to be a
guarantee that there will be no hard
Irish border whatever happens and he's
also said by the government's to be if
you like the fallback position that will
happen if Britain does not agree a new
trade arrangement with the EU by the end
of the transition arrangement in other
words by the end of 2020 there's the
explanation from all of you is there
anybody who thinks the backstop is good
if we leave the EU the reason why we
need the backstop is because the Chief
Constable of the peace service of
Northern Ireland has said that any
arrangements that lead to a harder
border between the Republic of Ireland
and Northern Ireland and having
different customs territories will lead
to a harder border will lead to mass
smuggling which will be funded and
leaped to the funding of the
paramilitaries and this will destabilize
peace in Northern Ireland that is the
reason why the Prime Minister has
negotiated the backstop but the best
thing to do is not to leave the European
Union in the first place okay there is a
case that is made for the back so um
Nicky Morgan the Prime Minister herself
chief brexit negotiator the Attorney
General the chief legal officer in the
house of comms have all said we don't
like this thing that we're proposing but
you know what shucks we've got to do it
in order to get the Prime Minister's
deal are you in that position
we don't want to be in it for the very
reason that actually it's deeply
unpopular at home and keeps us in an
arrangement which in order to to sort of
finish brexit if you like me
needs to be done so neither side wanted
to work I think for that very reason it
will never come into being and actually
the much more likely thing is the
transition period will be extended until
a free trade agreement is negotiated no
down and you do a very critical of the
backstop you've echoed the language the
poorest Johnson is used in articles
about being handcuffed and so on yes in
Brussels in Brussels the father brexit
speaks in Brussels it is often said that
the back stops great for Britain because
you get all the benefits of being in the
EU without actually paying the bill just
to finish the thought you get the access
to European markets beaten a the bill
and you're not under the European Court
of Justice and you don't have to abide
by free movement of people so why is
what they say and what is implied and
often stated in Brussels wrong in all of
you the short answer is if Brussels
really didn't want the backstop to come
into effect and if Britain and Ireland
also don't want it to come into effect
then we would take it out of the
withdrawal agreement the problem would
go away we'd be able to sign and vote
through the treaty and by the way I
think the single likeliest outcome of a
big defeat on the 11th of December is
that a different British prime minister
goes and does a more minimalist more
skeletal version of the withdrawal
agreement without the Baxter okay thank
you very much it's only open argument
yes sir hello I'd like to ask Nicky a
question is it a deal on the future
relationship or is it just a withdrawal
agreement and if it's just a withdrawal
agreement then surely you can't make any
claims about are insured future economic
prosperity on the basis of that it's an
interesting point we'll take some more
comments in the book that is interesting
that that is the first time we've had a
specific question on the economy in a
debate that's gone on quite some time
but let's just take a couple more points
yeah and this question is more towards
Daniel and Nicky do you think it was an
oversight of David Cameron in the first
place so paste an oversimplified ballot
in front of the British people so what
the referendum a mistake in the first
place
let's just take another one over here
and then we're going to get back to the
economy as a question yep yes I voted to
remain
I was outvoted and I accept that Lord
adonus can you please explain how it's
logical or democratic or right four
remain to be an option on a ballot paper
in a so-called people's vote because I
think you've confused the audience you
certainly confused me okay I can do the
same okay let's deal with the
gentleman's point just as a factual
statement we know that you are voting on
bet thought you're voting on a
withdrawal agreement that sort of
Allsteel if you like you're also voting
on a draft rather minimal statement of
the future trading arrangement with you
which will have to then be negotiated in
detail in the future but the core point
the journal is making is do we actually
know enough about our future economic
relationship with you to decide anything
very much at all so I think it's an
excellent question Larry please you've
asked a detailed question actually
because I think it does get down to
brass tacks exactly as Nick says I don't
think I did use the word future economic
prosperity I think I used the words
stability and certainty certainly in
relation to the gentleman over there who
talked about his small business because
actually the economic analysis has shown
that in all cases there will be a hit to
our economy through what is going to
happen what I did say I think in my
remarks was that I thought the prime
mrs. deal mitigated the worst of the
economic damage and that is backed up by
the economic analysis just to be clear
do you think you're advocating the Prime
Minister's deal because you think that's
the Democratic choice do you think we'd
be better off if we actually stayed in
the EU
well the numbers certainly look that way
it's very difficult with a counter a
counterfactual yes well I think the top
list yeah but the trouble with this Nick
actually all this you can't boil this
stuff down to yes and no it's too
complicated going back to the young
gentleman's question I haven't answered
actually the complexity means I don't
think I could get all this across in the
course of another couple of months
referendum campaign it is for MPS to
read 585 pages to read the biblical
declaration to read the economic
analysis to listen to what the Bank of
England and others are saying and that's
then for us to make that decision next
week
we owe our constituents our industry and
our judgment and our ability to focus on
the issues at hand
you were very clear that one of the
reasons you don't support this deal is
because you think it limits us from
forming future trade deals yes now the
argument the Prime Minister makes in
favor of it is that it protects existing
trade the sorts of jobs that you now are
in car manufacturing for example often
in some of the poorest areas of the
country often ironically who voted for
leave but she says if you lose that
just-in-time delivery you'd lose that
ease of trade across borders will go oh
you in effect saying look we may trade
off some job losses in favor of a great
deal of growth first of all why on earth
would Britain in any situation Deal or
No Deal impose trade barriers on EU
imports I mean that's that's just
unthink we want to make things more
expensive for British consumers or for
British businesses so that the all these
absurd treasury surveys about putting up
tariffs in the UK which will surely
respond to a No Deal scenario by going
the other way I think the question is
are something very specific was spot on
right this is important for people to
understand this this withdrawal
agreement can be voted through by
qualified majority in the EU but the
future economic partnership needs
unanimity and already Emmanuel macron
has said I will keep Britain in that
uncomfortable customs union unless they
agree to give access of their fishing
grounds to French skippers it only takes
one country to wield a veto so Spain
could make a similar threat over
Gibraltar Dublin could make a similar
threat over norm Ireland etc and this is
the problem that we by then have given
away the 39 million we'd have lost the
leverage and we are we are then relying
on the goodwill of the EU and our
negotiating skills is that anything in
the last two years that leads you to
repose faith either in the generosity of
the EU or at this Prime Minister's
negotiating abilities what Daniel is
basically saying there is that the
Canada free trade agreement is not a
realistic option because of what he's
saying is that no free trade agreement
can be agreed potentially if one other
EU country as long as we're not in the
concept
got us in the customs union as a
fullback they will have no incentive to
negotiate even if you talk over each
other
[Applause]
democracy is ruled by the people the
people cannot betray the people if you
want to stay in the European unit it is
your democratic right to do so is the
right thing to do I know you did the
idea that somehow the people can betray
the people if you took back to its
logical conclusion we would have won
general election never have another
right set aside race we are about to
give you the results of tonight's vote
but but just before we do let's give
people a chance at the end in the last
few seconds each if you would be honest
with us well amongst for amongst friends
nobody's listening whatever you want to
be the outcome explain to the ladies
gentlemen here and people listening I'm
watching at home what do you think is
likely to be what happens next Android
owners brexit is being defeated by Greg
sets let's be clear is imploding as a
proposition we have got to find a way
out of this implosion that's taking
place the way out because we're a
democracy is for the people so have the
option to vote to stay if they have that
option I'm convinced that they will take
that option they will vote to state and
we can put this nightmare behind us next
year and get on with sorting up the
problems of housing health education all
of those big pressing issues which are
being completely submerged by this crazy
attempt to wrench us out of Europe
Burhan it may be I mean I'm alone in
finding the word people's votes slightly
obnoxious I mean what the hell was the
last one an aardvarks vote I mean in
you began by saying I don't want to
patronize the British electric menu
setup but basically they've all been
lied to and they do you know what the
polls haven't showed people know exactly
why they voted they voted to bring back
the right to hire and fire their own
lawmakers and live as an independent
country as I said earlier than a slimmed
down version songs backstop as we say in
Brussels will be agreed along the lines
of it but if we do end up somehow with a
second referendum then I think that
there will be a general move by the
people who voted leave last time to say
we're not good at you know all of you on
your own on Andrew side said there's
never gonna be I mean Nick Clegg made
this hilarious speech at the Oxford
Union where he said there are gonna be
people like those Japanese soldiers who
nobody had told them that the war had
ended on their little islands in the
Pacific they're still gonna be banging
on and on about it write a speech so
rich in irony that it should hang in the
taters a kind of national monument to
what our politicians are like all of
those people ash town Blair major who
said there's never gonna be another vote
now I have the gall to turn around and
say yeah you didn't really mean it I
think if there is another vote we will
turn our backs on the process we will
not digitalize it and it won't solve
anything we'll be back still with the
majority not having endorsed the progeny
Logan you are the only person on the
panel and we think we've revealed in the
room who actually has a vote now you
will know having come hot thoughtful
mayors of Commons you can't meet anybody
in now so comments almost anyone who
thinks the Prime Minister will win the
votes the first time around so what
happens well I think that the first vote
will be undoubtedly challenging which i
think is what the whip say when they're
asking how do you intend to vote with or
against the government next week look I
think it's going to be very difficult
given on the basis of what people have
said I think a number my colleagues
unfortunately have come out so strongly
against the deal and walk themselves up
a hill they don't know how to get down
they are desperately hoping that
somebody before next week will give them
a way out of the position that they have
adopted if that doesn't happen if the
vote goes down then I think we should
listen to what the gentleman over there
said
about his business I think we learned up
in a territory of a potentially no
confidence vote in the government I
think that a second referendum despite
the fact that people who are saying
they're going to pose regime because
they're very much in favor of a a clean
brexit very much opposed it comes back
on the table but actually I think to ask
the gentleman over there who talked
about a second vote representatives will
do what representatives should do which
is they will establish a parliamentary
consensus actually I think their way
forward is a Norway plus option that is
what Parliament will unite around I
think that's what will get the sign-off
and then that's what we'll have to
basically agree and move forward to
implement so this is the moment you were
waiting for which is the results of the
debate just to stress again for people
both in the room and watching elsewhere
no one is claiming that this is a
representative audience is an audience
of people who wanted to be here tonight
in Westminster and have paid to come as
well but what they have done is listened
to the arguments and they have voted as
they arrived and they've also voted at
the end of the debate so those people
voting with Nicky Morgan in favor of
Teresa Mays deal before the debate 18
percent after the race 19 percent
[Applause]
those who voted in favor of the
government trying to renegotiate the
terms of this deal and threatening to
leave without a deal agreeing with
Daniel Hannan before the debate 19
percent after the rate 27 percent
[Applause]
and finally those who want a second
referendum if that's what you call it
some people call it a people's vote some
people call it a third referendum before
the debate 46% of people voted for that
in this audience after the bait that
went up to 53% because
the car ladies gentlemen the undecideds
fell from 17% to 1% so it just remains
for me to thank our speakers who I think
you will all agree in this room showed
passion showed intelligence but above
all in a divisive debate showed courtesy
and respect to people that they disagree
with
I want to thank intelligence squared for
making it possible I want to say goodbye
for me Nick Robinson and everyone here
in Westminster in London
[Applause]
[Music]